ici le studio 3 est bien voici la
première statistique qui nous soit
parvenue elle porte sur
67300 suffrages exprimé pour le général
de Gaulle
39159 voies pour Monsieur François
mitrant
28142 nous allons immédiatement calculer
le pourcentage qui ressort de ces
chiffres
merci mademoiselle le pourcentage est
donc de
58,18% pour le général de Gaulle et de
41,80% pour Monsieur François Mitterrand
et pour la petite histoire voici la
dépêche qui est arrivée la première à
20h01 ce sont les résultats pour
colomber les deux églises il y avait
191 votants 190 suffrages exprimés le
général de Gaulle a obtenu 178 voies
monsieur Mitterrand 12 voix et on a
trouvé dans l'urne une enveloppe vide
pour les autres résultats à vous
Jean-Pierre Chapel
voici un premier résultat qui nous vient
de Nevers dans la Nièvre je vous
rappelle que c'est le département de
Monsieur François mitrand sur 5000
bulletins général de Gaulle 2050 voix
monsieur mitrant 2920 voix nuls 30 un
résultat de Kajar la commune de Monsieur
Pompidou dans le Lot sur 100 bulletin
général de Gaulle 55 voies monsieur
mitrand 45 Mulhouse Haut-Rhin sur
23557 bulletins général de Gaulle
11735 monsieur mitrant 6300 long le
Saunier Jura sur mille bulletins sous ça
ce sont des résultats partiels sur 1000
bulletins donc général de Gaulle 610
voix monsieur mitrant 361 mesdames
messieurs
tout d'abord je précise que les chiffres
que je vais donner
portent sur l'ensemble département des
départements de la métropole plus la
Réunion la Nouvelle-Calédonie valise et
Futuna
manque ton corps les résultats de la
Martinique de la Guadeloupe de la Guyane
de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon des Comores
des appareils ça et de la Polynésie
mais les résultats de ces départements
et territoires d'outre-mer ne peuvent
pas modifier le sens des résultats que
je vais vous lire
inscrit 28 millions 971 637
votant 19 millions 994 117 soit
69,1%
exprimez 18 millions
69753 soit
64,53%. ont obtenu
Monsieur Alain Poher 7 millions
voies soit
42,22% Monsieur Georges Pompidou 10
millions
801932 voies Monsieur Georges Pompidou
sort victorieux de cette élection
nationale avec
57,78% des suffrages exprimés
élus président de la République pour 7
ans il prendra officiellement ses
fonctions de chef de l'État le 20 juin
c'est-à-dire vendredi prochain date à
laquelle la mission du président
intérimaire son concurrent malheureux
prendra fin
la campagne active
d'abstention menée par le Parti
communiste le PSU et les groupes
gauchistes et loin d'avoir répondu à
l'espoir de ses instigateurs en effet le
pourcentage des abstentions et de
30,99
%. il est donc seulement de
[Musique]
8,57% de plus qu'au premier tour mais il
convient de préciser pour être complet
que le pourcentage des bulletins blancs
et nul et passer de 1% au premier tour à
5,47% au deuxième tour
quant à la répartition des voix entre
les deux candidats un phénotables est à
signaler Monsieur Alain Poher qui avait
obtenu 5 millions
268 417 voix au premier tour totalise au
second tour 7 millions
821 voies soit une augmentation de
2627 821 voies dont une grande partie ne
peut provenir à l'évidence que de
l'extrême gauche
un mois et demi de campagne
présidentielle
précédé d'une longue campagne
référendaire se déroulant l'une et
l'autre dans le calme on démontré
l'impartialité de l'appareil de l'État
et apporter la preuve du bon
fonctionnement des institutions
démocratiques de la Cinquième République
je regarde la pendule avec vous 59
minutes
20 30 secondes très exactement la voici
à l'antenne et nous allons attendre
ensemble
leur fatidique c'est-à-dire 20 heures
à 20h seulement nous serons dur de vous
donner une estimation
une estimation qui vient d'arriver sur
mon bureau et que je vais vous lire
maintenant
dans moins de 10 secondes
5 4 3 2
1 il est 20h
jusqu'à
50,9 Mitterrand
49,1 je répète Giscard 50,9 Mitterrand
49,1 c'est l'estimation
ORTF SoFresh j'appelle jacquesidy à la
soif pour confirmation Jacques Didier
n'est pas disponible pour le moment dans
38 secondes 38 secondes et bien nous
sommes donc dimanche 10 mai 1981 le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle nous vivons ensemble un
moment décisif dans quelques secondes
effectivement 15 25 secondes par 25 ans
à l'heure dans quelques secondes vous
allez connaître le nom du Président de
la République
en tous les états majors un peu partout
dans tous les foyers on attend ce
résultat effectivement vous l'aurez à
l'heure précise
5 4 3 2 1 François Mitterrand est élu
président de la République
nous répétons donc estimation C2i
walbull Monsieur François Mitterrand est
élu président de la République
51,7 % Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
48,3%. Monsieur François Mitterrand est
élu ce soir président de la République
avec selon notre estimation
51,7%. voilà nous aurons maintenant vous
découvrirez le visage du nouveau
président dans quelques secondes dans
une trentaine de secondes Paul peut rien
dire pour l'instant ça va pas tarder je
crois qu'on tient l'antenne pour vous
dire que dans maintenant 5 secondes vous
pourrez découvrir le président voilà 35
voilà mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
voici le nouveau président de la
République en quelques secondes je vous
confirme ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
la participation a été plus forte qu'au
premier tour cela veut dire qu'il y a eu
mobilisation au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle à qui cette
mobilisation a-t-elle profité nous le
savons tout de suite
[Musique]
voilà donc l'image de ce nouveau
président de la République François
Mitterrand vient d'être réélu selon
l'estimation bulbea avec
53,9% des voix ce qui veut dire on va le
voir tout de suite que Jacques Chirac
obtenu ce côté
46,1% de ces mêmes voies 53 9 pour
François Mitterrand et 46,1% pour
Jacques Chirac un tout premier
commentaire pour la main François
Mitterrand président de la République
pour la seconde fois de sa carrière il
bat un record c'est la première fois
sous la Cinquième qu'un homme est élu au
suffrage universel direct deux fois de
suite il est 19h59 et 39 minutes
40 secondes 44 45 46 48 49 j'ai sauté le
47 50
depuis Louis Napoléon Bonaparte
rappelons-le et rappelons au passage que
le septennat existe depuis en 1873 il
est 20h voici le choix des Français le
nom
et le pourcentage de la victoire pour le
nouveau président de la République
cinquième président de la Cinquième
République Jacques Chirac 52% des
suffrages exprimés aujourd'hui
Lionel Jospin 48% des suffrages exprimés
le nouveau président de la République
est donc Monsieur Jacques Chirac élu
avec 52% des voix c'est la joie c'est la
liesse on peut le comprendre avenue
d'Iéna au siège du quartier général de
Monsieur Jacques Chirac je vous laisse
écouter l'ambiance
voilà dans quelques secondes maintenant
il est 20h voici notre estimation des
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
Jacques Chirac est élu président de la
République avec
82,1% des voix Jean-Marie Le Pen
17,9 % des voix estimation hypsos
vis-à-vis tout de suite une image celle
du sel de la République non nous allons
alors retrouver Jean-Marie Le Pen à
Saint-Cloud Jean-Marie Le Pen est-ce que
vous m'entendez pour une première
réaction Jean-Marie Le Pen
alors je crois qu'on a un petit problème
de son et qu'on peut peut-être découvrir
l'image
des partisans de Jacques Chirac à la
République à moins que Jean-Marie Le Pen
ne m'entende
ce sera dans un instant voyez comment on
a accueilli ces résultats place de la
République il pleut sur Paris mais c'est
bien sûr la joie chez les partisans de
Jacques Chirac avec ce score
massif avec cette victoire très très
large beaucoup plus large même que ceux
qu'on attendait sans doute
82,1% des voix Ségolène Royal ou Nicolas
Sarkozy vous voyez leur partisans à
gauche et à droite ça y est les Français
ont tranché et c'est dans quelques
secondes maintenant que vous allez
découvrir notre estimation dont on peut
dire qu'elle montre un écart conséquent
voici le résultat de notre estimation
Ipsos Dell c'est Nicolas Sarkozy qui
était du président de la République avec
53% des voix résultat saluer par une
ovation de ces supporters salle de route
19h59 minutes 45 secondes et bien oui
nous y sommes voici notre estimation du
résultat de la présidentielle en ce 6
mai 2012
c'est François Hollande qui est élu
président de la République avec
51,9 % des voix 17 ans après François
Mitterrand la gauche revient à l'Élysée
victoire saluée par la clameur on va la
découvrir on va voir les deux solférinos
à la Bastille regardez ces images
Jean-Jacques aime Salem va nous les
montrer ces images de joie cette clameur
des milliers de partisans de François
Hollande dans la rue ils sont doutés ils
avaient bien sûr les indiscrétions à
Laurent il ne reste que quelques
secondes avant de découvrir notre toute
première estimation
Ipsos sopra Steria quel est le verdict
des Français pour ce second tour qui de
Marine Le Pen ou Emmanuel Macron sera le
prochain chef de l'État 12 secondes
avant ce résultat on va retrouver dans
un instant ce résultat après des mois de
campagne 6 secondes 5 secondes quel est
le choix des Français
il est 20h voici le nouveau président de
la République et cette Emmanuel Macron
avec
65,1% des suffrages qui arrivent en tête
et qui devient donc le nouveau président
de la République Marine Le Pen obtient
ce soir lors de ce second tour
34,9% des voix on va tout de suite aller
du côté du Louvre explosion de joie vous
le voyez sur ces images en ce moment
même au Louvre là où sont rassemblés les
partisans du candidat d'en marche
mouvement qui je vous le rappelle est né
il y a seulement quelques mois leur
candidat s'était lancé dans cette
campagne sans appareil sans structure
politique et sans militants c'est une
nouvelle ère politique qui s'ouvre en
France Emmanuel Macron et le nouveau
président élu il succédera à François
Hollande dans quelques jours à l'Elysée
et devient à 39 ans le plus jeune
président de la Cinquième République le
8e de l'histoire en comparaison Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing avec 48 ans lors de sa
victoire en 1974 Emmanuel Macron a
réussi ce pari audacieux que beaucoup
croyaient impossible bousculer
l'échiquier politique français s'imposer
face aux parties institutionnelles
[Musique]